they're breaking developments tonight
about the links between Christopher
steel the Justice Department and a
Russian oligarch tied to Vladimir Putin
joining us now with more
Washington examiners byron york who's
breaking the story tonight byron tell us
what you have learned well we're trying
to find out about the origins of the
dossier long search and what we found
out was through some new emails that
have been released is that the dossier
is author Christopher Steele that former
British spy was in touch with an
official at the Justice Department Bruce
or a lot earlier than we thought that
we're exchanging emails in January of
2016 and what was interesting here is
that Steele was writing to to Bruce or
at the Justice Department and he was
talking about a Russian oligarch Oleg
Deripaska and door Deripaska had been
involved with Paul Manafort in the 2000
litigation with each other he's suing
he's not a fan of manna for although he
doesn't think what's happening to man
afford is fair
they both claim the other one was
stealing from the other his visa was
revoked for a while because of
suspicions that he was involved in
Russian organized crime Deripaska that
is details on that has never clear it
appears that Christopher Steele when
he's writing these emails is kind of
lobbying for Oleg Deripaska saying well
he wants to come back to the United
States for a meeting and it looks like
he's gonna get a visa and that's a
really good thing because we're hearing
he's not really a tool of the Kremlin
and it was like he was lobbying on his
behalf and you're thinking what in the
world is going on here and then these
conversations kind of morph it mid-year
2016 into a dossier can't conversation
he's saying you think Oleg Deripaska had
something to do with the dossier I don't
know he was in contact with Christopher
steel maybe he can have two
conversations going on at the same time
why do they have to be related that's
entirely possible when when when Mark
Warner the Democratic leader on the
Senate Intelligence Committee wanted to
get in touch with with Christopher
Steele he went to this the publicist who
worked for excuse me the lobbyist who
work for both Deripaska and Steele it's
it's just an odd situation then mid year
2016
Christopher Steele says - or we need to
talk I need to talk to you about some
other business but I specifically wanted
to discuss with you informally and
separately and it concerns our favorite
business tycoon and now most people who
have read this believe that's Donald
Trump because that's just a few days
before Christopher steel actually tells
the FBI gives them the first installment
of his dossier which is that famous
Moscow hotel room scene so does that get
us further down the road to determining
the original provenance of the dossier
who contributed to it or just well it
gets us further down the road into who
in the Justice Department the US
government knew about what was going on
and when they knew we still don't know
that we still don't know the details of
that which is unbelievable after all
this time they don't want anyone to know
that because even if you're in Congress
and have subpoena power it's locating
the information yeah well there's a
reason they won't give us information
fascinating stuff Byron thank you so
much for that report tonight